okay so Jael a league of one god his
story is amazing if this story had been
released as part of DC Reavers then it
would be the best thing come at a DC
beware for real and for true like it
would be the best thing coming out of DC
Weaver because this story is so good so
here's a little bit of backstory to this
a little bit of exposition so to speak
the reason why this is called JLA
instead of Justice League of America is
because after crisis on Infinite Earths
there was no Justice League of America
there was no flash Wonder Woman Green
Lantern Superman so on and so forth
there was no cohesive Justice League
team there was Justice League
International but there was no cohesive
like core Justice League team JLI or
Justice League International was just
like that man leading a hodgepodge of
people who just couldn't hold their own
book so there was actually a pretty
genius idea there was a way for DC to
basically expose fans to characters that
they would normally never read and we
got to see some really really cool
interactions like Guy Gardner getting
just like decked by Batman in one shot
it was pretty cool but let the debates
of the arguments and things like that
they would have we're always pretty fun
to read but in 1998 DC brought back in
the Justice League of America and they
simply called it Jay LA now in truth
I've actually been trolling with this
idea we're going to cover new 52 Justice
League when the Justice League movie
comes out so we'll cover like Darkseid
war and all that kind of stuff and that
will segue directly into the Justice
League of America DC rebirth it's the
reason why we stopped Batman when we did
endgame is because the stories bloom and
epilogue actually create continuity
issues when it comes to a Darkseid war
and like Batman being the god of
knowledge is so on and so forth it's
easier to just stop within game and then
just jump into Darkseid war with justice
reso but nonetheless you know it was
really kind of a cool thing but with JLA
it was designed to basically focus on
the Justice League of America as a core
team almost like in the post-crisis
landscape so it was basically like we
were getting the team for the very first
time and we got some really really cool
stories power battle so on and so forth
but this is actually an original graphic
novel meaning this does not fit neatly
into any continuity it just gives us the
Justice League of America team in a
particular story that took place
somewhere DC just doesn't really tell us
where but the fact remains here that
this is cool because it shows Wonder
Woman with a pretty ingenuitive state
but it also really focuses a lot on like
them as follows you that goes on with
the Wonder Woman landscape of the fates
and the lighthouse light Oracle and
water nymphs and tree nymphs and
Bagon and her beating the hell out of a
Justice League it's really cool it's a
really really cool scenario so initially
what this does is this basically picks
up with a dragon by the name of dracool
car Fang now the cool thing about this
is that we basically get this this
scenario at least as done by you know
Christopher Christopher Miller or a mole
I came over exactly how you pronounce
his last name but it basically kind of
delves into a little bit of legend and
hearsay with regards to Dragons and
we'll get to that later on here in a
little bit but what it tells us is that
in the early days of earth within the
realm of DC Comics Dragons did exist and
that makes sense in DC because I mean
we've got the whole Greek mythological
pantheon DC's very real world and very
grounded with regards to how they do
their comics so in the real world we
hear stories of dragons and old
different things like that
I mean how that gets rectified in the
real world I really don't know I haven't
looked too much into it I don't imagine
just like really big lizards I have no
idea but if that remains like legends of
dragons and monsters and sea beasts and
I mean we know the Megalodon shark is
still alive so I mean at least I want to
believe that's the case so things like
that are probably true but the fact
remains here that this delves into the
idea that Dragons were very very very
arrogant very haughty but we're also
like rulers of the land and that falls
in play with the idea of dragons as we
think of them and the same man serves
dragons not in the sense that they
really wanted to but in the sense of
they just kind of had to but for the
most part the Dragons were effectively
hunted to extinction and rakul was
basically the last one now the caveat to
all this is that dragons were not easily
destroyable the reason why is because
the only way to really kill a dragon was
to basically destroy its heart but
dragons would hide their hearts they
would literally remove them from their
bodies they wouldn't be actual hearts it
would be something that represented the
heart of a dragon like a crystal or
something along those lines but it would
basically be the core of its existence
and the dragon would hide it somewhere
so the dragon could just kind of like
fly around and it would virtually be
indestructible so long as nobody ever
found its heart now eventually this
basically led to Joe cool just kind of
taking up refuge and hiding eventually
you know the armies of the world tried
to track it down but were ultimately
unsuccessful and simply walked away and
so all we really knew is that for eons
untold
this dragon just kind of existed in
hibernation and that was really it and
so what we do is we actually
fast-forward by several hundred years -
2001 - basically to the JLA now again
because of the fact that this is
original graphic novel most all Oh G
ends basically treat whatever team or
character they're talking about as if
people are reading about them for the
very first time and it makes sense
because again these don't fit into
existing continuity you couldn't really
go read JLA and expect to find this
story in there somewhere you would just
have to kind of walk around a comic book
story and then just see JLA League of
One it's like well I wonder what that is
and you see Superman only cover Wonder
Woman you pick it up DC has to treat
readers like they've never read these
folks before so again this really
emphasizes the idea that the Justice
League of America is as much a
humanitarian team as they are a combat
team in the sense that they exist to
vote serve and protect as well as like
beat the hell out of bad guys so because
of that because of that they've actually
had monuments erected to them really you
know the probe actually gifted the
Justice League a monument basically has
their names made on it it's made of
Perry and Marvel the same material that
Michelangelo used it's basically one of
these instances where the various you
know humans of the world whether they're
in very powerful religious positions or
political positions or just the average
person expresses their appreciation for
the actions of the Justice League by
presenting them with gifts now under
normal circumstances the chanceless
League would say no right like like if
somebody walked up and was like hey I
really want to thank you for saving my
family here's like a giant bag of money
the Justice League would probably say no
they'd be stupid for doing it but don't
probably say no and so because of that
this is just really one of those things
where it has an intrinsic value to the
league because it shows the appreciation
for the team is on a pretty grid a
pretty grandiose scale now at this point
we switch over to a place called alt
Dorf us which one I think it's outdoors
I'm not sure how to pronounce that
properly a lot of those pronunciations
when it comes to a lot of those nations
in Europe I am terrible with so I
apologize if I butchered the name of
your town I'm really sorry and we
actually in the picking up with a couple
of goblins now these guys are not wildly
important essentially Elmen and Emeric i
think is what their names are but the
reason why they're a century or at least
the reason why they're introduced here
is because while they as individuals are
not the most important most important
thing in the world the actions of the
goblins as a whole are important and the
reason why is because they descend from
various goblins that had served dragons
and paths now the idea was that
following the defeat of the Dragons
there was really no traditional role for
the goblins to undertake at least it
seemed to be the case and so they just
really kind of fell down into the realm
of just capturing gold and kind of
living underground and
doing whatever it is that you know they
end up doing in their spare time but
eventually they stumble across the tomb
of your cool and when they do the idea
is to basically wake her up and then
continue their role as serving a dragon
now the funny thing about this is that
this is one of those scenarios where you
know stories turn into legends turn into
myths turn into hearsay you know no one
really knows or at least they don't know
exactly how things used to be all that
really happens is the good stuff is kept
and that's par for the course I mean if
I were for example to you know outline
to a bibliography on your entire life
you know the good and the bad then as
time progressed if for whatever reason
you became some sort of religious figure
people would begin getting rid of the
bad things and only keeping the good
things shining you in in a positive
light it just makes sense that after a
while that would be the case and that's
essentially what happened and it would
regard to these goblins and waking up
you're cool they're not you know looking
at this like yeah it's going to be
amazing because she's going to like
raise the world no no they're looking at
this and saying oh it's going to be
amazing because we will finally have our
purpose back we will live up to the
greatness of our ancestors we will serve
this dragon and restore ourselves to our
rightful place now at this point we
switch over to Wonder Woman and this is
when we start to get into this whole you
know mythological aspect of things in
the sense that we actually pick up with
up there now okay as far as I'm aware is
like a wood nymph more or less and in
the realm of Greek mythology remember
this correctly and I am by no means an
expert on Greek mythology nymphs are
basically not really like crime gods but
they basically represent different
aspects of things so like wood nymph
you'll find them in the woods you know
they can kind of manipulate the woods
and grass and trees and so on water
nymphs are much the same way they exist
in the water they can manipulate
different facets of water different
things like that but this wasn't really
almost kind of ties into the Wonder
Woman myth though so this really just
kind of Christopher kind of giving us
this tour of the Wonder Woman landscape
the different kinds of nymphs and gods
and goddesses she comes into contact
with the kind of powers that are
bestowed on her whenever she spends time
with them how they grant her gifts and
boons and different things like that for
example turning her into a mermaid you
know temporarily and so on and so forth
but ultimately she's brought before the
Oracle of Delphi now this again I think
it's Delfi I can't write how to
pronounce that but again this is one of
those scenarios where the role of Wonder
Woman and the life that she leads
transcends traditional earthly concepts
which is to say that she leads a life as
a superhero but her allegiance is also
very much to the Greek god Pantheon and
the various things that are entwined as
part of it
so when the Oracle of Delphi basically
speaks up and says there is going to be
a great threat coming that individual
who's going to be you is going to battle
this threat and is going to die along
with all of her teammates
Wonder Woman takes this as an absolute
truth she basically says okay according
to the Oracle a dragon or some major
threat you know some enemy a fire and
flame is going to show up I'm going to
have to fight it I'm going to die in the
battle and so are my teammates then she
takes absolute allegiance to this and
that's the important thing here is
because at this point it's no longer an
issue of her basically kind of
functioning alongside the Justice League
and keeping them arrest from this point
forward it is she's going off basically
going rogue and doing her own thing now
with regards to to the main JLA
themselves again this is designed to
kind of give us a little bit of the
inner workings in this one so you have
John Jones who's basically saying hey
here's everything that's going on right
now across the world we don't really
need to band together to face them off
but we do need to kind of deal with them
you know deal with them appropriately
now the reason why these scenarios are
being introduced is because it basically
gives Wonder Woman the opportunity to
incapacitate each member of the Justice
League when they're dealing with a
threat in the Amazon they're dealing
with solar flavor they're dealing with
an asteroid that's heading toward Earth
and so on and so forth the tanker that's
basically washed up on shore and
threatens to flood the ocean with oil
because of that this basically allows
John Jones or at least it allows the
Justice League to split into individuals
you can go and deal with these various
threats or team up or whatever the case
may be but it puts them in an otherwise
weakened state now under normal
circumstances this wouldn't matter
because unless like Darkseid is
attacking or something along those lines
there really is a you know much of an
earthbound threat that could lead to the
Justice League's complete and total
destruction if they were individuals and
for the most part they can all deal with
their own threat but an attack from
within from Wonder Woman presents a
pretty credible scenario now also notice
Batman here and that's the cool thing
about this Batman is like he sees and
knows all right like he's in any
situation and he's immediately
calculating what all is going on with
everybody's body language is saying so
on and so forth but the way that
Christopher actually deals with Batman
here is pretty cool and we'll cross that
bridge you know here in a second but
it's pretty cool the way he like depicts
Batman's intelligence because it doesn't
make him like this end-all-be-all
I know everything kind of guy he's very
much a guy that simply knows how to use
the tools at his disposal so much is a
guy that knows everything that goes on
so the result is that everybody's
effectively paired up the flash and you
have Batman who are going to go to the M
because it basically looks like poison
ivy is manipulating trees and so on and
so forth to basically flood a lot of
local villages and towns Superman is
going to go check out the solar flare by
himself because you know Superman and
then you have the ol Kyle Rayner the
Green Lantern is going to go deal with
this asteroid and Wonder Woman and
Aquaman who is going to go who are going
to go deal with this tanker now again a
lot of this is designed because of the
fact that these guys would pretty much
excel in any one of these particular
situations superman derives its power
from solar energy makes perfect sense
for him to go check out a solar flare
kyle rayner the korean green lantern
because remember at this point in time
in the DC landscape Hal Jordan basically
lost his mind become parallax and was
believed to have died and so car Waner
basically took its place as Green
Lantern
he's a spacefaring guy so it makes sense
that he would go deal with asteroids
poison ivy is an enemy of you know a
Batman and anything that has to do with
the oceans Aquaman gets pissed if you
end up screwing it up so because of that
with one of them being so strong really
being almost as capable as Superman
which is something they're going to
focus on here in a little bit she ends
up going of course with with Aquaman
himself now with regards to the actual
idea of jerkle this is when we start to
get into the very dangerous nature of
dragons in the sense that one of the
things that Jon Jones also talks about
is that there have been a series of just
bizarre and rash robberies that have
taken place around Europe and no one
really seems to understand what it is
that's going on I mean like candlesticks
pots and pans different things like that
but again the reason why this is done is
because of the fact that these are all
basically items that are made of gold
and they're being stolen for the purpose
of appeasing to cool now again we'll get
to that here in a minute but the fact
remains that with the goblins working to
cool up this is when they basically
begin to you know they begin to receive
more than they bargained for you're
cruel does one of two things either she
basically obliterates you know whatever
goblins are here or she takes some of
them and transforms them into dragon
gnomes now this is kind of a weird
scenario because what Christopher plays
on here is very much committed mythology
of dragons or just to say we're given a
lot of scenarios on what your cool does
but we don't know exactly how she does
it she simply just does and so actually
again when we get to Wonder Woman we'll
talk about that a little bit but the
fact remains here that picking up with
with that man in the flash again it's
Batman basically saying okay you know
Wonder Woman was acting kind of strange
we're going to leave Robin item as she
left behind a little strand of hair sub
along those lines and we're going to
analyze it and move on now of course
because Martian Manhunter is supposed to
be the telepathic link for the Jeff
he's actually the first one to be
incapacitated by Wonderwoman now the
reason why this matters is because going
into JLA really in the stories following
that and even to some degree in kneel
before the JLA martian manhunter was
kind of like the linchpin for the team
right because he had celebrity what he
would do is he would basically create a
network for each member of the Justice
League so that when they were off facing
their own threats if Wonder Woman was
suddenly like oh man there's this major
threat that I can't deal with on my own
or if that man was like man there's this
major threat I can't deal with on my own
the other members of the Justice League
would hear it and they would respond if
they were capable of doing it so it's
basically how each one always knows
where the others at but what a woman
taking out Jon Jones it's pretty smart
it depicts her intelligence and her
capabilities and the fact that she knows
her teammates extremely well kyle rayner
is the next one she actually takes him
out once he returns back to the to the
Justice League Watchtower she kind of
engages with him a little bit and then
takes his ring away and so he simply has
no power whatsoever he's easily knocked
out with Aquaman it's the exact same way
of course she moves the moves at anchor
out of the way and then immediately
seizes Aquaman and drops him off with
with the water nips you know with neon
so again it's really kind of a cool
scenario to see here because she's
incapacitating each individual member of
the league in the way that can easily
keep them subdued and keep them held
away for any real measure of time now
following this we basically pick up with
this idea of CRISPR kind of toying with
the notion of dragons and ester cool
makes her way through these different
you know areas immediately kind of
focusing on outdoor the idea here is
that she basically is just imbued with
hatred
you know deceit anger wrath so on and so
forth and this basically permeates out
to the rest of society at large sending
this city into absolute pandemonium and
destruction now half of this destruction
is you know you're cool and her forces
just kind of raising the city the other
half are the people who are just turning
in on each other you know just kind of
becoming inherently violent what seems
to be happening here and the indication
that's given to us is that it's really
more of like a empathic connection more
so than like a telepathic connection
meaning that you're cool for whatever
reason is able to basically enhance the
emotions of hatred and anger as opposed
to like telepathically taking over the
minds of these various humans and
forcing them to fight each other again
this is very much kind of delving into
mythology it's very much kind of delving
into giving us scenarios without giving
us any real answers that's kind of the
cool thing is it creates a mystery some
intrigue
it doesn't give us every single answer
to every single question we have and
that I think is actually a mark of good
storytelling if every question you have
gets answered then it takes away your
ability to just kind of answer it
yourself make up your own answer kind of
ponder it for a little while because it
interests you it doesn't really leave
any mystery or intrigue there so I kind
of like this is what's happening that
we're not really given definitive
answers now with regards to the flash
and Batman the cool thing about this is
that while the flash is easily able to
take out poison ivy
Batman basically grabs her I guess he
access to the computer in the watchtower
over the little thread that it is
analyzed now this is why I say the way
the CRISPR depicts Batman is cool
because some writers what the victim is
just knowing everything Batman is just
like I have observed Wonder Woman's body
language and I know exactly what's going
on
some writers will do that and it's it
stretches the limits of credulity even
for colleague blood but when you have
something like this where Batman's
basically just accessing this computer
system and says analyze that sample that
I gave you in the computer says okay you
know I'm analyzing it whatever it
basically goes all the way back to a
particular location and then Batman
deduce is that this is basically from
the range of the Delphi from the Oracle
of Delphi tracing it even further
cross-referencing it with all these
weird little scenarios of thievery and
these weird you know burglaries that are
taking place ultimately comes back to
this realization that is all coming out
of a place called alt Dorf and then
after that the question is you know why
are things being so on so they must
analyze myths
analyze legends this doesn't seem to
make any sense let's try dialing into
things that don't make any sense this
eventually leads him to the idea of a
dragon you know that in 1348 the Prince
of Amadeus I'm sorry a story of the
Prince of Amadeus and the dragon and
then from there it's just kind of
expanding and kind of going on now we as
readers would kind of look at that and
say well that seems kind of silly but
when you're talking about a story that
exists in the realm of like an alien
from outer space with super-strength and
a guy who can run super fast and a Greek
mythological being you know who came
from some Paradise Island that fights
against you know various enemies of so
on and so forth it's not that far out of
the realm of possibility especially when
you're dealing with Wonder Woman and
that's why Batman is going to these
lengths with regards to the flash this
is kind of a cool scenario because
Wonder Woman would not be able to take
out the flash and hand-to-hand combat
just because of the fact that he's too
fast and so instead she actually uses
the environment against him in this
instance it's a wood nymph that actually
trips him up it basically just kind of
breeze up you know a little bit of a
branch
and trips and results in him falling now
the way the CRISPR does this it kind of
gives us two scenarios that we can sort
of toy with the first is that either he
just reduced the speed of Wally West
while he was running the second half is
that it could just be that Wally West
just isn't running as fast as he could
and that makes sense I mean if he's just
like hey okay I defeat a poison ivy
let's go find Batman he's not going to
run it as absolute fastest speed he's
not going to run so fast that he can
outrun the universe he doesn't need to
he's just like let's just go find Batman
so it would be like you just kind of
walking at a casual pace except for the
flash he's walking insanely fast so
because of this you know it's easy for
him to be kind of tripped up now the
other half of this is wonderful in
toying with the flash himself in the
sense that Wally kind of has this
tendency to say okay look you know I've
achieved my goal I can let my guard down
now and because of that preying on that
moment allows Wonder Woman to basically
incapacitate him and knock him out now
also it's an ally and so Wally you know
the flash would have no reason to
believe that Wonder Woman would be out
to get him now of course following this
and following to know the flash
basically being taken by Wonder Woman
and put in stasis that and of course
grabs a screen up and says what tell me
everything you know now of course this
is under threat of coercion basically
the idea that it'll cause some kind of
crazy biological reaction to or whatever
the case may be but all these guys are
basically being put in pods with the
intention of sending them out on a
course so I'll actually find out what
this is and it's really a genius
decision by Wonder Woman but again
Batman kind of arrives on the scene and
says look that weird little tree never
told me everything that's going on now
this is kind of cool because Batman
actually makes Wonder Woman out to be a
villain here what he basically says is
if what this Oracle said is true that
some thought is coming and that you have
to face it and then if we all go we're
all going to die then you should trust
us like there will be a way for us to
make it out of this alive Wonder Woman
is feeding on this notion that she has
with regards to Greek mythology that's
kind of the cool thing is when it comes
to everything that goes on in DC Comics
Greek mythological gods and so on and so
forth there are some things that the
Justice League will not be able to
understand and it has nothing to do with
the fact that there dies it has
everything to do with the fact that they
simply just don't come from that part of
the world they have never lived that
life so we'll deal like you as an
American trying to understand you know
are trying to relate to the inner
workings of your French society that is
deeply rooted in tradition
you're not from that life you couldn't
really understand that life you could
educate yourself but at the end of the
day you would never be a
person having a family that goes into
all that steeped tradition that was just
that's never going to be your life and
that's how it is with Wonder Woman you
know with regards to her her existence
the way that she functions you know she
comes from a world but none of the other
superheroes can ever comprehend in the
same way but none of them can ever
really understand what it means to be a
Kryptonian because they're not
Kryptonian so again it's kind of a cool
scenario but ultimately she ends up
incapacitating Batman and actually
defeating him now the weight is she's
forced to do this is with her lasso of
truth because the lasso cannot be broken
by someone unless they deny a legitimate
truth are really Wonder Woman unless she
denies a legitimate truth and even then
I don't think the lasso can
traditionally be broken um it has before
but only under the conditions like this
story calls for it and this scenario
even if that man wanted to break that he
wouldn't be able to pull it off because
he's just a regular guy but that remains
that with Batman having been defeated
all that's really left is Superman and
so essentially Wonder Woman just kind of
goes about her business with the
intention of taking out this dragon and
Superman arrives on the scene now under
normal circumstances we would expect to
see this as a long drawn-out fight and
we would expect to see a great big huge
conflict like we saw in you know Wonder
Woman number 219 I think it was it was
an infinite crisis tie-in when she beat
the hell out of Superman that's not what
happens here instead uh what she does is
she basically kind of roughs him up a
bit
but she doesn't actually defeat him and
the reason why is because of the fact
that she basically says look I have put
Batman and I've put the Green Lantern
Kyle Rayner and I've put the flash in
pod and I've sent them to the asteroid
belt they've got 15 minutes or 10
minutes of oxygen remaining your job is
to go and find them now in truth if it
came down to it let's say for example
that Wonder Woman had just like tied
them up and left him in the watchtower
or just put him in stasis pods and
didn't actually jettison them into space
and it was just her and Superman
fighting she would probably win to be
honest because Superman would would like
pull his punches or something along
those lines but she would fight until he
was dead that would be her goal would be
to legitimately kill him and so because
of that you know she basically says look
your job is to go save the rest of the
Justice League but the reason why I'm
doing this is because of the fact that
there is a credible threat out there and
I'm the only one who can really deal
with it and so the cool thing about this
is that once Wonder Woman basically
arrives to confront you're cool this is
when a lot of this you know kind of
mythology begins to come into play
because of the times that you're cool
basically preys on defeat - preys on a
lack of confidence different things like
that
when
under woman reveals her name to the
dragon it gives the dragon a sort of
power over her now we're not given the
extent of what this power is that it's
just like exactly how it works it really
seems more like the power is able to
kind of harness her soul to a degree
maybe grab her essence kind of force her
into giving answers that she wouldn't
normally give but again it's not like
possession right it's not like she
speaks her name and the dragon just like
possesses Wonder Woman as long as she
speaks her name and the Dragons just
like now I have telepathic control over
you it doesn't work that way it's really
more of like a subtle influence over the
essence of Wonder Woman more so than
anything else but that's kind of the
weird scenario is because it's things
like Oh Wonder Woman's then bewitched
and so on and so forth and so ultimately
the dragon does not give its name to
Wonder will instead the dragon simply
says its name is like Joan of Arc and so
what this seems to indicate is that in
this realm of mythology and so on and so
forth the giving of the name grants a
person power over whoever it was that
gave their name and so where Wonder
Woman gave her name willingly to jerk
rule if you're cool were to do the same
thing
it would give Wonder Woman some measure
or influence over the dragon itself and
so from here she basically sees as one
of the dragon gnomes or whatever it is
and uses her lasso of truth to force the
name of your cool from the dragon after
which she basically says look I know who
you are I know what you're about I'm
going to go to your cave and I'm going
to destroy your heart now this is what's
really smart about this is the guest
Wonder Woman doesn't know where the cave
is she has no idea how to access it
instead by making this declaration by
making this statement by appearing to
the dragon and basically saying look the
fates have decreed that you are going to
die and I'm going to be the one that
destroys you well I wouldn't say it
scares the dragon it certainly gives
your cool cause for concern that's what
the result is that she actually takes
off for her own base Wonder Woman hides
and watches where it goes and so again
that's the coolest thing about this
story is because it shows us that Wonder
Woman is really really smart she's very
ingenuitive she's very cunning she's not
just some really good-looking chick who
can just beat people up you know she's
actually very capable in the kind of
things that she can do now from here
once she arrives inside the cave of the
cool she's met with Elmen now again
element is one of these goblins that
basically wasn't turned into a dragon um
but element provides a lot of
explanation and a lot of discussion here
with regards to the nature of you're
cool and this is again really
Christopher just kind of grabbing one of
the different mythological
interpretations of why dragons love gold
so much and this has been told in
different ways
some stories that say that dragons love
gold because they just love hoarding
witches there are others who say the
dragons are inherently drawn to gold and
so dragons just kind of have this
compulsion to grab gold in this scenario
what we're basically told is that
dragons actually feed on gold and when
they eat this gold the gold in turn is
absorbed and it basically adds to their
scales making them harder making them
more durable not only that because of
the fact that wars have been fought over
gold because of the fact that men have
killed other men over gold what this
means is that the evil nature of their
actions has effectively bonded itself to
that gold and by consuming it your cool
is basically consuming or really kind of
filling yourself with the essence of
evil now this raises some pretty cool
concepts and it's actually a genius idea
and the reason why I say that is because
of the fact that let's say for example
that a dragon is worn right if we were
to take this this nature versus nurture
stance we were to say that a dragon is
like a newborn baby it has to learn
about the world around it it's taught
what - like what to dislike it's taught
what to hate and what to love so on and
so forth if a dragon were to simply just
say okay you know I'm a newborn but I
eat gold in the same way that a baby
will nurse from its mother then by
eating that gold it'll basically become
evil because evil is tied to that goal
and so it's kind of a cruel scenario
because it would beg the question if you
had like a pet dragon and you just fed
it like hosts of snacks all day long
would it become bad I think it'd be kind
of cool to see somebody like feeding a
dragon Twinkies that'd be kind of cool I
think it'd be hilarious but again this
is really kind of cool Adele isn't a lot
of this mythology Adele's into a lot of
these you know questions these things we
don't have definitive answers to mostly
because dragons don't exist anymore
which I kind of wish they did but at
this point Wonder Woman making her
presence known to drew cruel leads to to
cool basically firing off this Bale fire
or Bain fire or something like that and
basically hitting Wonder Woman's own
bracelets now again what this does is it
basically says look because of the fact
that it hit these bracelets she asked
which are nice and destructible and it's
able to cause some measure of damage
then it would a minute if like Superman
or if flash or if Batman or any of these
guys had been hit by this fire it
probably would have incinerated them and
the whole statement of jakku that like
no mortal can survive the Bale fires
touch this again tells us that there are
things out there that just transcend our
traditional stance on superheroes that
there are all there's a great big huge
myriad of possibilities when it comes to
the
the landscape when it comes to like the
101 MIT those when you're dealing with
gods and goddesses and so on and so
forth there's all kinds of different
crazy scenarios that take place out
there now of course but from this point
it's really more up to cool kind of
messing with Wonder Woman one only kind
of shows up and says look you know
you've tried to destroy me I've survived
this clearly shows that I'm going to be
the one that takes you down but I do not
want to kill you instead
give me your molten heart and I will
hold it as collateral and is a good
faith exchange to show that I have no
intention of killing you now of course
if you're cool this kind of vows and
says yes you know you've shown me your
greater strength and then immediately
attacks Wonder Woman and races off with
her heart now again at this point it's
really more of a scenario of fear it's
really one of the first times in however
many millennia that rakul has been alive
that it began began to experience fear
because what is encountered is a being
that he can't readily destroy and so
because of this the conflict the final
battle between the two of them it's
actually pretty straightforward but the
idea seems to be basically confronting
evil with goodness now again a lot of
mythological stuff a lot of metaphors a
lot of unanswered questions but it's
really this idea that because of the
fact that Wonder Woman is able to wield
the lasso of truth it means that she
allies herself with truth she allies
herself with justice
she allies herself with righteousness
and so because of this she is basically
the antithesis of your cool essentially
meaning that good wins out over evil and
in this opportunity by weakening the
dragon using her lasso of truth she
interned destroys the heart of the
Dragon which leads to it exploding and
that's really kind of it I mean the
dragon was kind of blows up and the
fights pretty much over but again the
overall gist of this was to basically
show the lengths that Wonder Woman would
go to anywhere to protect the Justice
League and fulfill her destiny as a
warrior but it's also basically saying
that Wonder Woman is a woman of two
worlds she is an Amazonian and you know
part of the Greek mythological landscape
but she's also a traditional superhero
fighting alongside the Justice League of
America and she allies herself to both
and this becomes prevalent when Superman
basically says you betrayed my trust
that as a member of the Justice League
you should have told us what was going
on you should have kept us informed of
what it was it was happening even if you
were adamant about the fact that you had
to face it off on your own you should
have trusted us with this information we
should have come to this conclusion as a
team now again this is not DC saying yes
you know Wonder Woman cannot do things
by herself because she's a woman no no
it's not them saying that it's DC saying
that Justice League is a fan
they encounter problems as a team they
face those problems as a team and they
overcome those problems as a team that's
the basis of the team that's the
function of the Justice League is to
always face threats together as a group
and so ultimately when the question was
asked are you going to pull a stunt like
this again one of those response is the
Justice League is my family and if it
means I have to incapacitate all of you
again in order to make sure that you
stay safe that's exactly what I will do
and so that's the only promise that I
can give you I will fight you and I will
defeat you if it means keeping you safe
and going off to face some threat on my
own so again this story really kind of
wraps up at this point of me it's really
kind of brought you an end but in my
mind it's really one of the greatest
Wonder Woman's stories ever told I mean
this is this is absolutely amazing it's
almost as good as hickety I love take a
tale a whole lot more but this is pretty
solid anyway if you guys are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you out Leonard
[Music]
you